well
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition aka
the guy living his best life in the
worst timeline and this video we're
breaking down the finale of agents of
shield
i just want to get into the breakdown as
there's a lot of things to talk about
but obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend that
you turn off now
anyway with all out the way this is the
heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition now let's get
into the ending of agents of shield
okay so before tackling the mammoth
finale we need to discuss how time
travel
actually works in the show so that
things don't get too complicated the
further into the breakdown we get
throughout the show's ending we discover
that the seventh season has operated in
its own timeline
which we discover fractured off from the
main one which was connected to the mcu
an alternate reality has of course been
teased by things like the death of mac
and daisy's parents
however the finale actually uses this
alternate version of events
to tie into fitz's plan initially deeks
stated that they might be operating with
the time stream theory
which suggested that if they screwed up
the timeline too much
that time itself would collapse this is
why early on they avoided killing malek
and really messing anything up however
the longer things ended up going on
the more messed up they became and it
turned out that an
alternate timeline had actually been
created so
the group jumped back in time and then
after making changes
continued on a parallel timeline set off
by the butterfly effect
that they created all the way back in
episode 1. we learned that fitz and
simmons stole a piece of chronicom tech
all the way back in season six and with
this the former has been monitoring the
timeline
using the knowledge gained from it to
create a certain pathway
fit has basically been an opposite to
sybil and after viewing the entire time
stream
he realized that the only way to stop
the chronocomms was to save daisy's
sister cora
in the original timeline she'd killed
herself and this fitz's plan this entire
time was to create a timeline
in which this would not happen and cora
would become their ally enabling them to
defeat the machines once and for all
that's a basic bird's eye view of
everything but we'll discuss it the
further we get into the video
now episode 12 opens with mac daisy and
souza
where we left them last time the group
are adrift in space
making their way to the zephyr though
they manage to dock the zephyr itself is
pulled into the chronicom ship
using their tractor beam which of course
pulls them in two
eventually they bore this ever and find
it empty much to their surprise
it turns out that malik's forces have
left and all that remains is the guy who
used the word sir last week
which what a what a bloody scumbag now
we join malek walking down a hallway
that actually looks like something out
of the opening of the phantom menace
malik says to simmons and deke that they
have one last chance to hand over fitz's
location
but neither budge and because of this
they're thrown in a cell
it's at this point we come face to face
with sybil in the flesh well
sort of but since being destroyed by
coulson
she's managed to rebuild her body much
like he did
they discussed the shield bases being
destroyed and now all that remains is
the lighthouse
this is because due to the way that it
was built it can withstand
any major attack from the outside i
don't know why they can't just blast it
from space but yeah
apparently they can't now sybil has also
given simmons an injection
that can completely dissolve her implant
and thus she will find out soon enough
where fitz is
however we discover that this is
backfiring and that her memories are
dissolving completely
along with who fits is deco also does a
hilariously bad impression of fitz
but simmons still can't remember the men
she laughs
that was that was probably as good as
deke's impression now it's at this point
that cora confronts malik over the
killing of a mother
he tells her about how much her mother
hated her and lies about her wanting to
exterminate her
the conversation ends with him promising
to bury all those that tried to hurt
korra
next to jai ying and though not outright
stated
this is clearly hinting to her that
daisy the person carrying jae-ing's
legacy
will try and do the same thing to korra
we then jump with garrett to the
lighthouse and he places a chronobomb on
the wall
later in the episode may notices garrett
doing this throughout the entire complex
and they end up using a device that can
stop him from teleporting in order to
shut down his plan
this is actually a callback to when
coulson lost his hand
many many seasons ago in that entry
they'd managed to stop gordon in the
base
and coulson caught the terrigen miss
crystal that he was carrying
this started the inhuman transformation
process on him but
mack managed to sever his hand with an
axe before things took hold
it's through this device that they
defeat garrett and we actually get a
nice flip on his death which i'll
discuss in just a bit
now on board the chronocom ship daisy
gives susa a kiss and begins sneaking
around
which is when she catches the attention
of sybil sybil admits that she hasn't
been able to predict their actions
however she brushes this to the side and
says it's purely because they're
meaningless
so it looks like daisy was right in a
belief that sybil wouldn't be able to
predict her abandoning korra
and this does play into how their plan
actually comes to fruition
sybil believes that letting daisy
reunite with simmons will increase the
probability of them discovering fitter's
location
and thus she makes malik stay his hand
this allows daisy to sneak through the
base
which is why the chrono comes later past
her in the corridor malik and korra
decide to go against this though
and it's at this point i remembered who
malek reminded me of
evan peters he's i tell you what he's
bloody just like evan peters now at the
lighthouse
cole cena may predict the point that
garrett will arrive at due to it being a
key structural location
he does this and they manage to trap him
by using handcuffs that stop him from
teleporting
colson orders him to stop the attack and
he calls malik who
basically says no it turns out malik is
willing to sacrifice his new best bird
and he detonates all of the explosives
at the location
luckily yo-yo manages to get them all to
one location before they go off
which means that they don't completely
destroy the base through the rubble the
team dig their way out
and find garrett who they decide to save
this convinces him that the timeline he
was shown was incorrect
and that shield aren't actually that bad
it turns out that coulson actually used
himself to shield may
and though the pair don't get the happy
ending together it's nice to see that
they do still care about one another
at the zephyr the chrono comes arrived
to kill mac and souza
but the pair have other plans they
actually end up using the self-destruct
function of the chronocomms which is a
callback to earlier in the season at the
area 51 facility
one of the chronicoms plan to use
themself as a weapon in order to destroy
helios
and the two turn the tables on their
enemy by using this function against
them
i actually love the interactions between
souza and mac in this episode
and the latter becomes kind of like an
approving father throughout the entry
we watch as daisy gets to simmons who
doesn't recognize her however
she decides to trust her after she
promises her a costume
they make their way back to the zephyr
which is where simmons memories start to
return
as the implant begins to dissolve it's
at this point that cora arrives to stop
them
and daisy convinces her to do the right
thing and join their side
the pair realize that they should
actually join forces
much like how they should have done with
their mother in their respective
timelines
division between jaya ying and her
daughters never really led to a good
outcome
and thus they're putting their
differences aside in order to do the
right thing
back at the lighthouse carlson has
picked up a pattern in the strange
signals
which he realizes is the location of an
084
this has actually appeared in the series
quite a lot and actually means an object
of unknown origin
they decide to let garrett free in order
to help them and on board the chronocom
ship
malik comes across cora who's had a
change of heart
he stuns her and sends it to a cell
whilst the team get to the zephyr
and fly out of the hangar using the
chronicon bodies strapped to a missile
they managed to escape and love how they
kinda look like crash test dummies as
they went bobbing along to their death
now it's here that we jumped at the
speakeasy that we've seen dotted
throughout the season
this becomes a key location in this
entry and it's nice to see it pop up
throughout the entire series
a cool at least a reg also appears here
as we see garrett shot by a young
victoria hand
this is actually a flip on the original
timeline as in that it was garrett that
shot hand in episode 17 of the first
season
here they meet agent brandon gamble who
turns out received a package from his
grandfather who was in the ssr
he and others were told to protect these
084s at all cost
and they've waited their entire lives
for this moment at this moment an old
man shows up
staying that he received the final piece
from either enoch or the koenigs
enoch and koenig of course worked in the
same speakeasy together at one point
and we learned that the pair deposited
the pieces to build this machine
throughout time to specific people
using this last piece they open a
passage in which
a portal similar to the quantum realm
machine from endgame can be seen
with their wedding ring as the last part
of the puzzle fitz is pulled through the
quantum realm
donning the same helmet that deke wore
when he first entered the show
not gonna lie i was very happy to see
fitz back
even if it feels like it's been ages
since we last saw him now this was
obviously the same method that they used
in avengers endgame
and looks like fit and simmons have
managed to create the mobius strip
gps system that stock did in the film we
jump immediately into the next episode
and discover that fit has been in the
original timeline controlling the events
and hoping that the team make it to this
point with cora
fitz just wants to grab her and jump
back but colson says
they can't just leave this timeline to
the fight of the chrono comes
they hatch a plan to take the chrono
comes with them to their timeline
but in order to do this someone has to
stay behind
souza initially volunteers to do it but
deke
in the end puts himself forward i'm not
i'm not right now what i liked about
this
is that deke is actually from an
alternate timeline himself
so him being taken from one timeline and
then put into this new one
does make a lot of sense for the
character guys probably gonna have a
pretty good life
ripping off don't you forget about me
and hopefully michael jackson i'd love
to see him do smooth criminal now deke
promises
that they might see him again as he's
fit simmons's grandchild
and together they put their plan in
motion to pull the chrono comes back
the other shield agents look to dig for
their new director
and he actually becomes that a sort of
nick fury in their world
hopefully he gets an eye patch as well
and he can become the white nick fury
from the comics
as i'd absolutely love that and in my
head that's now the canon
now on the zephyr fitz pulls simmons's
memory back through the use of a story
which reconnects her to them fitz
reminds gemma of a childhood
in which she used to stargaze with a
father through the use of a favorite
star olya
fits pulsar back through and we see what
happened to the pair in season 6.
this is when enoch rescued them and i
also love how we get to see his
his eye robot skin at one point with his
own copy of the time stream
he's monitored what they needed to do in
order to stop the chronicle war
that's currently about to ravage the
planet after meeting with piper and
flint
they formed a plan and together the trio
traveled to a distant solar system in
order to build a time machine
here they spent years putting everything
together and they actually carved out a
life for themselves and had a daughter
named olya fitz worked on the time
machine using himself to view the time
stream
but the radiation decayed his brain
slightly and thus he couldn't handle the
diana implant which is why simmons ended
up taking it and traveling with the
agents
so last week when they were discussing
the blood works this was actually in
reference to the blood works that
doctors tend to take when someone is
pregnant
so though we probably got 80 of our
theories wrong
we got the one about their daughter
right we did it it wasn't
all for nothing but yeah we do kind of
suck
now on board the zephyr mallet gets
angry that sybil's plan is beginning to
fail
and he goes to korra's cell demanding
they strap her up to the power sucking
machine
the group split up and one team goes to
the temple from the season six finale
they don hazmat suit so that no one can
see their faces
and we watch as certain events from the
ending of season 6
play out but from the perspective of the
older versions of the characters
this shows mei getting escorted to the
healing chamber and yo-yo recovering
from the shrike attack
it turns out that the people in hazmat
suits at the end of season 6 were
actually this group
and huge props to the creative team for
planning this all out in advance
if they'd seen the other versions of
themselves then they would have created
an alternate timeline
and thus things remain unchanged because
of these suits so yeah no paradox and we
don't have to worry about any branch
realities
from space the chrono comes sends the
original zephyr moving
whilst the future one hangs there
waiting for them to attack
the past one of course travels with
enoch simmons and fitz de alia
and the one that's just been through
season seven boards the chronicles ship
so nice little pulling of everything
together here on the ship
daisy takes down the hunters whilst mack
and coulson make their way through it
they're ambushed by more of the chronic
forces and
daisy takes on malik there's a lot of
slow motion flying about but
but you know what it's quite a good
climax to end on
matt comes across cora and saves her
from the machine
while sybil almost almost busts out a
supervillain monologue
coulson stops her dead in her tracks
though and tells her that the shield
forces her at the lighthouse
she enters her authorization into the
command panel in order to send the
forces there
and mae arrives and busts up the hunters
with coulson
weirdly sybil is actually dispatched
really quickly
and for the big bad of the season i
thought she went out pretty
unceremoniously with very little of a
fight
at this point the chronicom forces move
towards the lighthouse and simmons's
memories come flooding back of her
daughter
on the main ship mae plugs herself into
the command kiosk
and through korra she passes on empathy
to the chronocoms
which ultimately disables them now i've
seen a lot of people confused over
what exactly is going on here but
basically it boils down to this
through enoch fitz and co realized that
the chronic comms could learn empathy
and thus if they had this they would
side with the humans
enoch and fitz's friendship was a
shining example of how the two can
coexist
and thus this became part of fitz's plan
thus
mae was able to absorb emotions through
her empathetic abilities throughout the
season
and pass them onto the machines who'd
all journey to the lighthouse under
sybil's orders
onboard the chronocom ship malik tells
daisy that there's no way to kill him
without killing herself
and she says that's the idea she sets up
a quake that destroys all of the
chronicum ships
and thus they're defeated daisy floats
through space
doing the blue thing that they do in the
mcu as she slowly starts to freeze
cora using the powers which he tried to
drop on jaya ying
is able to bring daisy back from death's
door and down on earth
fitzsimmons travels to piper and flint
who were not only guarding the time
machine but also their daughter
now there are some little monkey toys in
the corner and this is a play on the
running joke that fitz always talks
about monkeys
from pretty much the first season up to
now he's dropped the animal at several
points
so it's good to see that like father
like daughter
we see a montage of them raising her and
she would of course
go on to become deke's mother we then
get a big time jump of one year
and the group meet back up at the
speakeasy throughout shields history
bars have been the place where the
agents have said their goodbyes to one
another
and there's been several scenes where
they've raised a glass to the departing
members
the group meet up and share the stories
of their new jobs
and it's a really emotional scene it
turns out that fitzsimmons have raised
their child together
susie is still a thing and mae has a
brand new job as a lecturer
shield mack enters looking like nick
fury and he's continued as the director
on assignment
yo-yo is working with piper and everyone
seems
a lot lot happier colton has a lot of
things he wants to do
and we learned that he's been traveling
the world by himself
actually getting some time away from the
job now at this point i just want to
give a huge shout out to clark greg
and it's crazy to think that he started
with the mcu
all the way back in 2008 iron man and
now that anyone else will
ever have as many appearances as he had
in marvel properties
for a long long time carlson gets
offered numerous jobs and positions
but politely he turns them down it's at
this point that we realize they aren't
actually in the room
and they just sent holograms to meet
once more slowly they blink out after
saying their goodbyes
and they realize at one point pretty
much all of them had died
and you know what it was a really fun
way to close up the season
yo-yo goes first showing that she's in a
call with piper
and an lmd davis it's at this point that
you start getting goosebumps
and me appears with flint at the coulson
academy which is of course
dedicated to the character fitz and
simmons returned to their picnic with
olya
i'm not crying you'll cry mack explains
that he's left a package for coulson
which will open with the code 136. this
is a little nod to the series as a whole
as this is the 136th episode of shield
mack returns to being mcfury on a
helicarrier
floating through the sky leaving just
carlson and daisy
to say their goodbyes the two have some
really emotional parting words
and it's the perfect way to end this
series in my opinion
coulson disappears and then daisy pulls
out to reveal that she's on board the
zephyr with souza and cora
together they're conducting missions
throughout space and it is possible that
they will create agents of sword
on the set of one division sword was
spotted as one of the signs
and it is likely that the mcu could be
moving off in this direction with daisy
leading the charge
chloe bennett has stated that she wishes
to play the character for as long as she
can
and this definitely provides an avenue
for it nick fury at this point is of
course a drift in space with the scrolls
so who knows they may even end up
crossing paths
on earth colton opens up the briefcase
and finds a car key which he tracks to
lola
coulson's old ride carlson started up
and
then transforms from red to black this
was something that was in the comics
and nick fury himself actually did it at
one point
choosing black much like how coulson
does here
we see coulson fly off and they the
triskelion in the background
though it was destroyed in the winter
soldier it's back here
showing that shield was rebuilt and that
the agency still exists out there
even if we won't be following the
overall stories of the characters
now what this could also answer is
whether the show is actually connected
to the mcu or not
at this point in the timeline the snap
has been carried out and half of all
life has been wiped out
however the world we see is fruitful and
vibrant
so they may exist in a timeline in which
thanos did not win
who knows it could even be a
continuation of the 2014 one
in which that version of thanos was
killed at the end of end game
i kind of don't want to sour the ending
by talking about whether it was
connected or not though because
you know what it's been a great series
and it doesn't really matter you can
kind of take it how you want to
overall this was an excellent way to end
it in my opinion
and watching our favorite characters
ride off into the sunset
or rather sun was an excellent way to
bring shield to a close
now there are lots of avenues that
marvel can take things if they want to
but if they don't this was still a great
way to end the series
anyway that's the entire season and i'd
obviously
love to hear your thoughts on the show
as a whole like what you've loved
what you've disliked and how you think
the show will be remembered
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and if you missed our analysis of any of
the other episodes then make sure you
check them out after this
we will be covering lovecraft country
from next week and the boys in september
so make sure you stick around for
breakdowns on those
don't forget that every month in the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning the mcu infinity soccer box set
is leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you